[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast we
have a reappearance of the lovely Teal
Swan today since I interviewed her it
was probably a couple of years ago now
the show's been around enough years I'm
starting to bring people back and we
became really good friends so I really
really love and enjoy teal she's very
sweet and very smart and wise and so um
the episode today was a lot about
ancestral healings and that essentially
let me just break it down being
fundamentally the most important thing
that Humanity can do right now and that
there's a choice Point happening and we
we really need to choose to fix these
patterns so that we are a positive
benefit in the universe so that other
entities want us here so that we don't
we don't let our nature become like the
nature of AI and because it's just
feeding off of our patterns you know
what's the point of all this because
it's not always going to be easy I can
promise you the more that you heal the
more joy and the better perspective in
life you have like it doesn't mean it's
always going to be easy but the overall
Baseline of the life that you live just
gets better so say yes you can get her
program on her website tealswan.com
please hit the Subscribe button and the
bell for notifications and let me know
what you think in the comments today's
pretty intense partner is athletic
greens I take ag1 by athletic greens
literally every day I gave ag1 a try
because I wanted to nourish my gut
health I wanted to have more energy I
wanted to add more micronutrients to my
body I take it first thing in the
morning before I have coffee and then
before I go work out it makes me feel so
good I'm giving my body the nutrition it
craves if a comprehensive solution is
what you need from your supplement
routine then athletic greens is giving
you a free one-year supply of vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase go to athleticgreens.com
prettyintense that's athleticgreens.com
pretty incense check it out
I talk to people that are experts in
this all the time and I still forget all
the time
like it's so easy to forget how powerful
the mind is yeah why can't we stay there
like is it that I mean is it possible to
stay there we get pulled into first
person perspective so easily we forget
that we're the ones using the mind we
confuse ourselves with our mind we are
the witness Consciousness that is
behind and is creating these different
layers of the cell layers of the the
identity
creating thought creating emotion
creating physicality
so it's like I'm we are simultaneously
the thing we have created at the same
time we're not that thing we have
created right yet we're watching it and
we are in it so we have these two points
of perspective it's just very easy to
get lost in only this point of
perspective we could call the Avatar
right
completely easy to get lost in that
which we have created then we forget the
bigger picture then we can't step
outside of our thoughts then we can't
witness our thoughts then we're not
learning about ourselves we're just sort
of stuck in ourselves and yeah I can't
really curious what is inherently part
of this Human Experience like what is
just
is pain inherently part of this
experience is
I wouldn't I would imagine you'd say yes
to contrast
are all these things just part of the
human experience that we have to learn
to deal with and then I mean then I want
to ask if the if there we there's a
reframe needed like because if pain and
contrast and all the things are actually
part of this reality for growth and
expansion then you know let's just use
our mind and change our perspective on
when things are hard what's inherent
things like contrast things like pain
are inherently an element of of human
existence reframing and changing your
mind and changing your perspective is
just one tool that you can use to deal
with the fact that that's an inherent
element within this time space reality
and it's not like we're just here to
accept that either I mean most of the
incredible expansion that's taking place
in this universe and within the human
race is taking place because of our
directly facing that contrast which
inherently exists and doing something
with it like we could consider it to be
contrast that we couldn't fly and now
here we are in these metal objects
thousands of feet in there because of
looking directly at that contrast so
expansion comes from contrast in the
same way that Lotus Blooms from
mud so
why is it hard
like why does it feel why does growth
feel painful
because we wait for so long
honestly the problem with with the human
species as opposed to other species if
you watch it is that the minute that
there's a desire
and there's something that is unwanted
there's an immediate movement towards
what is desired and the human species
doesn't function this way
the physical human keeps himself or
herself completely apart from what they
want
and then by virtue of doing that that
gap between where they are and what they
are wanting continues to grow and this
is what suffering is about it's it's
this whole thing you know that I could
call my desire and that ironically my
non-physical self becomes the
vibrational match too immediately
um
it is this gap between here and here
that creates the pain in life
so I'll give you an example
um
let's say that
a person is frustrated with their
financial situation
and so they desire more abundance
in a typical species there would be an
automatic movement towards more
abundance but with a human let's say
that they grew up in a family where
there was a lot of negative Focus put on
wealth you know people who are wealthy
are awful you know
XYZ I mean whatever this family is
saying about wealth or is the mo they
have about it would make it so that this
person who might want to go in the
direction of abundance for themselves
feels like wait a minute by doing so I'm
going to lose some aspect of my
belonging with my family
and so they hold themselves apart from
that which is wanted
and we have all kinds of reasons why as
a people we hold ourselves in this
suffering but that is the thing you can
say about a human is that they hold
themselves in suffering unnecessarily
because it's a pattern is it because we
just want to repeat the pattern because
even though it doesn't
even though it's not good for us it we
don't die and that's essentially like
what the ego in the self is trying to
save you from a greater pain or
something like that
yeah but ego is always wanting to
prevent pain right right little tricky
bastard it cares more about preventing
pain than it does about its own Survival
funny enough
but it's really like it creates pain
obviously like that's why we're all
laughing but
it's not wrong because it actually is
less pain in the moment but it's very
short-sighted
yeah sure status it's it's difficult
well part of Awakening is to be able to
increase the Consciousness enough to
start to see these Ripple effects
so it's not just about the immediate
action it's about what that action
creates
in your future and in your children's
future and your grandchildren's future
the picture just gets bigger bigger and
then obviously the action changes when
that picture gets bigger bigger so I was
talking to a friend about something
similar to this but it had to do with AI
is that because we just are going to be
able to hold more information more
frequency more data because in my in my
psychedelic experiences there's so much
information in there I'm like I can't
like I need a break
um I every question there's an answer
like it it's over overwhelming how much
information and so the what's come
through for me is is that that's why we
have to have amnesia and forget because
it's too much we'd like would short
circuit for real
um but my friend was talking about
um and she's very spiritual and she was
talking about helping to create an AI
that will
um be able to be an intelligent and like
a a good AI that would let's say when
you buy
um you know a glass for water like part
of the AI knows like the ripple effect
of what created the glass so there's
just more information in that so it
leads to a more environmentally friendly
a more uh informed
um and smarter choices moving forward
that are better for the planet for each
person for Consciousness because because
there's more data and knowledge about
where just each and everything comes
from so does that make sense you're
seeing the positive potential of AI yeah
but but to increase one's Consciousness
or awareness to achieve a state of
Enlightenment is to increase one's
capacity for that type of information
which is why at a certain point you can
comprehend all your previous lifetimes
and you're not going to short sort it or
shut down or blow up I know we're going
to talk about ancestral healing a lot
today so I think that's an easy
transition into one of the first steps
in it which feels like reincarnation
like
and how what role that plays in it yeah
and how that even happens like the
pathway for reincarnation
if we're now pivoting from remembering
all of our lifetimes okay so so
reincarnation is very poorly understood
because
what's happening with reincarnation is a
mix of free will and determination
determinism I should say um
law of attraction in this universe
applies not just this one lifetime it
applies also to the cycle of
reincarnation in general
So based off of of what we are doing in
this current life we are a vibrational
match to in the next life
but it doesn't work in in all that
drastic of a different way than you and
your current life right now if I showed
you a person and I said is this person
making a choice
for the person that they're in a
relationship with
the answer would be yes that person
would be like well yeah consciously I
definitely am choosing to be in this
relationship or to get married to this
person
I could definitely throw a wrench in the
spokes though and I could be like but
what if I told you that the reason that
this woman is attracted to this man is
because he has all of the traits that
her father has
and because he has all of those traits
the minute that she meets him she feels
home now that's an example of
determinism so what we're seeing there
is that both are taking place at the
same time she's using her Free Will at
the same time there's a whole lot of
elements of determinism that are going
into that choice of partner and the same
happens outside of this cycle of
reincarnation so let's say that you were
you're standing in this space it's
really not a space we're just
conceptualizing of it this way but
you're standing in the space where
you're able to see all these potential
lifetimes you have memory of the
previous one you just came out of and
several more before then
you're looking to create expansion so
what is my path of expansion from
everything I've gained so far it is that
point of perspective that causes you to
choose into that next Incarnation but
you can only be a match to the ones
which are currently in your vibratory
Spectrum so
that has a lot to do with you know the
choices you've made in previous lives
and XYZ so it's a it's this beautiful
sort of coming together
of the element of of um free will
as it applies to the cycle of
reincarnation and determinism which is a
byproduct of everything that has come
before
do we actually kind of remember our past
lives maybe we don't remember finite
details and you know so many things we
can have remembrances but but think but
like I think about old souls or people
that are just mature you know they just
get it they grasp it they grow like
there's just peop some people are
different so do we actually kind of
remember past lives totally depends on
the person where their aspect of
Consciousness is where their level of
Consciousness is I've met a lot of
people who think they remember past
lives and they had no such life it also
gets more and more and more and more and
more and more complicated when you get
up to this this level where this whole
picture is taking place because we like
to think about ourselves as like a clump
of energy that comes into a sort of meat
suit over and over again and that's not
the picture of what's Happening Here at
all Consciousness oh like water really
what is happening okay so I thought of
it like that but oh hell no so
Consciousness functions like water and
and if you're if you're taking like an
above
uh look at a stream of water what you're
noticing is that there's all these
branches and all these splits yeah
Consciousness itself can split like that
it is a waste of time in this universe
for a clump of energy first of all it's
not a clump it's a stream but for a
clump of energy to come down into one
Incarnation and then go back up and then
coming down into a clump it's like a
waste what's happening more here is this
stream of of energy is coming down into
multiple incarnations at once so
the likelihood of there being many
embodiments for the stream of
Consciousness going you know creating
your
uh your awareness the one we're calling
Danica right now
um but likely that there being hundreds
of those right now simultaneously
walking the Earth it's very very high so
you're all of them and all of those are
your past lives
you go even further than that and and
it's like we're just creating a
differentiation so a stream of
Consciousness that like what I call what
I would call Danica is a stream of
Consciousness within the stream of
consciousness of your uh Soul family
within the stream of consciousness of
source and and we are the ones that are
creating that differentiation there it's
a little bit like when we look at the
ocean and we see a current in the ocean
is the current the ocean yes so what is
it making it so that we're saying that
current is different than the rest of
the ocean
we're noticing and identifying some
something to differentiate that water
from that water it gets to the point
where we're like splitting hairs like
absolutely splitting hairs yeah
um
it is possible to increase one's
frequency to the degree where you can
you can track your passive progression
through multiple incarnations
problem is when you're doing past life
regression or something like that the
majority of people are not actually
recalling quote unquote their their past
life what they're doing is from their
current vibratory state
they're essentially being shown a life
that is a vibrational match to whatever
they're currently experiencing so of
course it's going to resonate
of course
um that's why it works it works through
identification right now I could go
higher than that and say that every life
has ever been lived is your life
because this is all one everything every
life has ever been lived in your life
people get lost in past lives and this
is why my focus is actually to bring
people towards ancestral trauma because
the way that they're thinking about
about past lives is in fact the way to
think about ancestral
influences
okay now decide uh differentiate that
okay so ancestral influences quite
literally the biggest factor that you're
playing with here that goes beyond your
own current life like it it blows
in this past cycle of incarnation out of
the water
so let's say that you're sitting here
from non-physical perspective and you're
thinking about coming into a different
Incarnation what you're essentially
doing is watching
everything that goes into any of your
potential lines
so that means you're looking at multiple
parents
their combination on what month right
you're looking at the the entire
consciousness of every family line
that's coming into the picture of this
family tree that you're considering
incarnate into because you know that by
doing so you are essentially activating
and coming in as the progression of that
specific Consciousness so we do not come
here a clean slate at all we
intentionally come in
through that that story of that that
larger family line
and we inherit everything
our hair our little preferences are
scars yep I mean it's insane it's If
people really understood it
they would be shocked now obviously
there is there's a there is a self that
is beyond all of that right that's the
one that can do the choosing like the
one that can do the choosing does not
necessarily have a quote-unquote
personality though right higher self the
that's what a lot of people like to call
it that yeah
okay
um there is an aspect of cells that can
essentially choose into this that's the
witness consciousness
yeah
but oh man I mean if you really knew how
much
how much what you're opting into plays
into the bigger picture of your current
Incarnation I mean people would be
essentially doing ancestral stuff
immediately yeah because the point well
actually that's the good what is the
point of this Human Experience
depends on the person's life
um there isn't a macro per point to this
the macro point of life itself is a
human
to progress self-awareness within the
Universe At Large perfect so
you choose dynamics that create
self-awareness
oh you're no it's more complicated than
that so
that's the macro picture that's what
we're all kind of doing here but it's
much more fun to look at an individual
an individual is looking when they're
coming into a family line for a win-win
scenario they're looking for a family
line whose expansion would be served by
themselves and that that includes that
picture of their previous incarnations
and everything that they've already got
in their Consciousness up to this point
they're looking for a situation where
they would cause that expansion by
virtue of incarnating in there and at
the same time there are detrimental and
beneficial patterns or character traits
or elements within this this family line
that serves the intention that somebody
has for their current life so I'll give
you an example
let's say you've got somebody who from
non-physical perspective is is very
intent on being a teacher right
that's one of the things that they
wanted for their expansion about that I
want to be a teacher now it would make
sense to come into a family line where
we're one of those character traits is
oration
where where you don't have as strong of
a fear of like public speaking
potentially or something like that
um but you're not you're not like
looking only at the things positively
you're going to get out of it you're
also looking at these negatives
essentially
if you if one of your intentions for
coming down to life is to understand
love you're not going to Incarnate most
likely into the family that understands
love you're going to be like oh right
I've come down here specifically to take
that one on to be the one that works
through that one and that's also a
picture of what each one of us is doing
in our family lines we are here not only
for the gifts but also we're here
because we wanted to take responsibility
usually for one major theme that's
happening and transpiring through those
Family Lines
so it's got to be hard right I mean you
gotta earn it and one's going to be a
disaster
can you do you do you do you know what
you came here to do
yes
yeah out of each one of my family lines
for sure with my father's line
um there's this pattern of incredible
emotional neglect
moving through that line
and I'm here to master the Turning
towards the family at the same time as
turning towards endeavor
that it's not just one or the other for
my father's line it's always been the
other it's literally the most
enterprising endeavoring type of the
family lion ever everybody's just like
looking at the New Horizon and what
they're going to create and then these
nurturing needs for these children is
just completely ignored it's almost like
being born into a family of reptiles
where the progeny just pops out and then
like lives its own life you know
and there's a lot of obviously like a
lot of mental illness comes out of those
types of patterns a lot of people that
can't Thrive because they didn't get
those original emotional needs met so I
have come here too
be the one that essentially Masters
those those elements of of emotional
connection for my father's line the
mother's line is actually where I'm
doing much more work though
with my mother's line
that that family is a corrupted line if
you want to know the truth um what I
mean by that is that each each child
that is born is born with a very
specific type of innocence in that line
okay now we could say that all children
are born with a type of Innocence but
you all you have to go to do is work in
a daycare to see how different these
different people are what's interesting
about my mother's line is that every
child that's born in that line is born
with this incredible innocence I mean
far beyond what is normal for
or you know a baby even it's like a type
of Purity which is
you know I mean it's just it's so light
but it gets corrupt
and I mean corrupt so bad that
essentially each person within that line
becomes the nightmare for the Next
Generation so the pattern that's running
through that line is is Living With the
Enemy and then having to cope with
living with the Enemy by becoming
corrupt oneself
so it's like this you know each each
baby's born with this incredible light
and it gets snuffed out snuffed out
snuffed out
so I came here to work with a lot of
themes of abuse on that side a lot of
themes of antagonism and and sort of
Living With the Enemy Dynamics within
the household
um I came here to restore that sense of
Innocence so it's like can we preserve a
sense of faith when we have every reason
to have lost that Faith Can we preserve
a sense of connection when everything in
US is wanting to pull away from people
so it's the preservation of Purity
essentially that I'm trying to exact
through that that female line of my
mother's and part of getting through
that is to deal with massive amounts of
anxiety because
these these patterns essentially of
going against
um
against the self
that create
essentially a vibration that causes a
huge huge huge huge issues with
like tragedies and I'm talking like head
spinning level tragedies
where generation after generation it's
horrific out of the blue accidents
so everybody in this family has this
this like everything bad's gonna happen
it's like something horrible is right
around the corner and backing out of
those that type of vibration is super
important for me also
so that's a lot that's a lot you're
doing good high five
so it also feels like what I'm hearing
is almost like an example
of one of the aspects of the fractal
nature that we live in like we have
lessons within the life we keep getting
you know keep getting the same situation
presented in front of us and it's up to
us to choose but then also incarnations
are like the another fractal nature of
like okay you keep getting lives and
like this is your problem every life
every life this is your problem and then
one of these lives you fix it so what
the hell do we do fix it well I should I
should stop either because guess what
most of the time when we're dealing with
these themes of recurrence in our life
it's actually an ancestral pattern we
just don't know it right so
what are the signs what are the signs I
don't know is that where we start what
are the signs if somebody's like I don't
have ancestral
no no one's exempt so we'll just say
that no one's exempt absolutely nobody
is exempt and everybody has come in here
opting into a deck of cards some of
those cards are awesome some of those
cards crap while playing with an
ancestral deck of cards
okay it's about you know how how well we
can do it identifying those and even if
we can't so let's say you've got a
person who
they were adopted they have no access
you know to any of the records of where
they came from those patterns are still
alive within you yeah I mean they've
even the ancestral memory is something
that which is being studied on a
scientific level in a very intense way
yeah
and epigenetics is just taking us to a
whole different universe and it's no
longer a conversation where people get
to be like oh I wonder if it happens we
already know it happens cellular memory
yep they've already done studies like
tons of studies on on survivors of
extreme situations you know they're
human but the animal studies are just
out of this universe with how many
generations after a certain trigger is
introduced the progeny exhibits a
sensitivity to that very same trigger
without having ever been exposed to it
themselves and without ever having been
exposed to the parents that's where it
gets even more scary because we've got
these two different types of ancestral
traumas you know that we're working with
which one is direct and one is indirect
we could consider that an indirect
trauma so there's no way that this adult
mice could have taught the younger mice
anything it is literally simply
inherited but we've got both of these
things going we've got the the indirect
and social traumas that are coming to
our extremes and we've got the direct
ancestral traumas we'll talk a little
bit about that one direct and social
trauma is because of something that
happened before there was adaptations
within the family to it which were
dysfunctional adaptations and that keeps
passing down in the way that the parents
interact with the children so that
suddenly you are being interacted with
in a way that actually damages you but
it came from some trauma back in the
1800s which is part of why when you know
we're sitting here on the verge of War
I'm like you know because people again
short-sighted they have no idea the kind
of changes that creates even in you know
four generations past them you know one
of the things I feel like I've
red seen heard about ancestral memories
is that what when you heal
an ancestral wound it heals Seven
Generations both directions so how old
can an ancestral wound be
OG an ancestral one can literally go all
the way back if it's not changed here's
the key was there somebody in that
family that changed that pattern if so
they were the ones that healed it if not
it can be running all the way from us
deciding to walk away from Africa I mean
it can be way back
we could consider that the first
codependent act in a family line I mean
you know
what if we don't what if we don't what
if uh what if you don't have kids
does the ancestral healing still it
still matters and it still works because
you yourself are part of this
consciousness of the family line so we
could look at Family Lines in terms of
of progeny being just that next step in
the line but you yourself are still a
part of this family Consciousness like
another fractal it's like another fact
like the family lines are like we think
of it as like oh I have a mom and a dad
and a brother and a sister but it's
really like you've got your family line
is this Soul Reincarnation of
thousands of people yep
yes
so it's where so it's where do we want
to focus like is the question do we want
to focus on just the direct line or do
we want to focus on the overall sort of
web because you're part of the web still
so anything that you're doing is
essentially impacting any other thing
that's connected in that web so any
change is going to affect anything that
comes after you whether you're the one
actually having them come out of your
body or whether they're just connected
in that web
um yeah and obviously healing this kind
of trauma dynamic in the ancestral lines
is one of the most powerful things you
can do for for the children that are
coming into these lines but it's also
important to understand that they
themselves are the progression of the
family line so we've got a lot of
problems in fact when we start to look
at at progeny as if they're supposed to
fall in the footsteps of what came
before them you won't see any beings
being born in a family line unless they
themselves offer some kind of an
antidote or they themselves are the
progression for that family line which
is why it's so important to be looking
at children as if they've come in with
this gift for the family line what is it
and the kind of culture that nurture
rather than the pass down or inherited
traumas to them or pull them back sort
of enroll them backwards into our
dysfunction
and to understand that these children
are the gift
for this healing and growth and
expansion
but it won't be easy
which is why children are always so they
test you like I don't know I don't have
them but you know you always hear that
from people it's like my greatest
teacher is my kids man
it's a kind of a beautiful image where
Generations before
affordable gifts
in all kinds of different forms to the
progeny and the progeny themselves are
born with this gift that was not not yet
realized by any of the people coming yet
and they sort of turn around and give it
to the whole family line
so what is it that actually creates the
change
when it comes to ancestral stuff oh all
kinds of different stuff
um
ultimately you want to think about
healing ancestral traumas as changing
patterns if you want to make it as
simple as possible I mean there's
there's all kinds of different
activities that you could do
to bring about that change but
ultimately ancestral healing is about
changing patterns we start with a
pattern that is detrimental something
that is not really serving the family
line or the self
and we alter that into a pattern that is
oftentimes that's that's close to the
opposite of whatever we were dealing
with so if we've got like oh look in the
family line you've got this pattern of
abandonment
okay well what's the opposite of
Abandonment really sticking in there
with somebody
we could be part of the opposite type of
family though we could be part of a
family where one of these detrimental
ancestral loyalties is
that no matter whether somebody's
abusing us or not we're family
so there's no boundary in this family
around how one is personally treated so
the first person to set a boundary for
how they're personally treated is
actually changing the pattern within the
family line
really let's get nuanced about it
because I think the hardest thing is to
know where the hell to even look like
what where the where the hell to look
well okay so that's the first part of
this whole process the first part of the
process of ancestral healing work is
research right it's it's where you put
your sort of nose to the grindstone to
find anything that you can find now that
can mean talking to members of the
family that can mean hiring genealogists
I mean it can look however it looks
researching history
you just want to get as much as you can
and and it's got to be that good I mean
some people will be able to get a ton
some people it's like you know they're
they're limited to like a genetic test
where you know because they don't have a
relationship with anybody they're
limited to like a genetic test that
tells them well this is the general area
where your people are from and then
diving into the history in those places
and diving into the culture in those
places but so so it's like we can we can
almost treat it in this broad sort of
racial way or this broad cultural way or
we can or and we can hone it down to
these specific individuals and find
details on their life and you know find
Historical documents and put all this
information together and this is where
it's just like the better it gets the
better it gets
yeah and so many people when they start
off this
they're like oh I don't even know where
to start because I don't know if we have
this information and I I'm telling you
if you just start getting nosy the
amount of stuff you unearth will shock
you it reverses your identity like
nobody can go through this process
without having an identity crisis
and a truly awesome one because it's
like instead of it being like Oh I don't
know who I am anymore it's like it
clicks everything into place
so so you start by researching and based
off of this research you start to see
Trends so like even if I mean it gets
better and better the closer and more
down individual this gets but even if
all I'm working with are sort of
cultural themes if I study the culture
of you know say Germany
you know now and back then I may notice
some of these cultural traits and be
like
ah I see that one
so like for example you may notice that
that in let's say you've got German
ancestry you might notice that Germans
have a real issue with emotions
it's almost like well we we're real good
at taking care of each other on the
physical level we've got that down now
but like we there's such thing as
emotional anything
now I'm looking in myself maybe and I go
okay I noticed my own tendency I don't
want to deal with emotions I just feel
you just change your mind like why do we
have to deal with emotions now if you
recognize one of these patterns then you
know that's the ancestral trauma to work
with yeah yeah
are there archetypes
like are there can we can we like deduce
things down to like there's the
abandonment wound there's the not being
enough not deserving wound like are
there some like archetypal wounds that
we could sort of go through a checklist
and sort of use our own experience
within our life and our parents life and
maybe our grandparents life I'm sure
that somebody could put something like
that together because as human beings we
would be working especially because our
social lives are so predictable around
the world we would probably be able to
identify themes that cross cultures or
even themes that belong to certain
cultures that would be an interesting
work I've never done that work before
um myself personally I tend to more take
the individual and have them dive into
what it is that they're seeing and
feeling well that's that's great if you
have a teal that can help you right like
if you have a teal then that's the best
way but not everyone gets to have a teal
so
it seems like that would be a way
because you know you said it like or
think of us as pattern machines so
it's like we're a simulation I mean you
can look at like when you look at like
um astrology you look at Gene Keys you
look at human design you look at
um you know all these different things
that can or personality tests that say
you're an ifmjb or whatever
Briggs something
um there's so many ways that we can get
sort of clumped and bracketed or even
like Love Languages like the five love
languages like we can we can fall into a
very small amount series of
patterns
so
does it even matter if we're a
simulation I'm curious what your
perspective is on that because
like there's a thought that right we're
just a simulation and we're like a
holographic computer game running
does that even matter do you think that
even matters if we were does it change
the way that we think or feel no
besides I I don't I don't actually agree
with that
what do you think
I've okay so in this life
the game we're playing and the one
witnessing they're both real they're two
different realities they're they're
simultaneously real so when we when we
use the word simultaneous it means not
real it means not happening why does
simultaneous mean not happening when we
use the word simulation yeah okay we're
saying it doesn't it's not happening
yeah that's what we're saying when we
use the word right we're trapped in an
illusion okay well what are you gonna do
with it
I don't agree with this I feel like
what's actually happening here is that
we're looking at different
different elements of reality
so this thing that we have created here
that we could call a simulation is
something that we have created it is
real
it is made of the same energy that is
comprising everything in this universe
including what is behind this that we're
now calling real
um it's just where is it where are we
currently focused are we are we sort of
zoomed out and focused back here this
more non-physical perspective or resumed
in focused more in this physical reality
both are real
it's just
there are two different elements of
reality this is not the full picture of
reality right
that's what people need to remember
so what's the next step then when you
kind of are able to
collect enough information about your
history your lineage where you came from
then what do you do
you identify patterns that you want to
work with and things you want to round
so one of the big big uh I would say
mistakes that people make with ancestral
healing is that they think it's all
about negativity
and all about getting rid of the
negative in fact one of the biggest
elements of ancestral healing is what
you're going to own and what you're
going to embody and what you're going to
revive
and and every family line without
exception has these incredible traits
running through them and you know we're
talking aptitudes we're talking
preferences affinities you know
everything the same as to the opposite
side you could see aversions you know
weaknesses whatever it is so we need to
we start to identify what these
aptitudes are what these strengths are
it's almost like we're sorting through
the deck of cards that's the next step
after we look at these deck of cards
we're sort of like looking at what are
the positives here
and what are the negatives here now with
the positives we get to we get to own
and embody those so like let's say that
I start to notice that in my family line
there's a lot of people who are
proficient in music
okay well maybe doing ancestral healing
then means to dive more into music how
do I want to make that look do I want to
pick up one of these instruments and and
learn to play it
um do I want to start to write music do
I want to listen to more music I mean
there's this guy's sort of the limits in
terms of how a person really wants to
move forward with that and it would
surprise you
how quickly people know
it's not this is not something that's
very confusing for people it's like once
they've got their finger on it and you
go okay well what feels like the best
thing to do with that aptitude that
you're seeing and they're like this I
mean they can look at you dead in the
face and say it it's like there's this
Instinct as to what a person needs to
heal that ancestral trauma right
um so to the opposite you're looking at
these negative themes and you're you're
sort of like picking out maybe negative
things the family did those would be
those negative ancestral karmas right
you're picking out those negative
patterns that you're watching over and
over again this traits you dislike like
maybe in this family you see lying over
and over again this family has an issue
with lying like every single person the
story is that I keep hearing they have
no issue lying
okay so then you know I'm gonna be
working online then like how let's work
on telling the truth and then you start
to you know yourself explore your
relationship to telling a lie in what
cases is telling a lie okay in what
cases doesn't harm people
yeah and so it's like you're shining a
light on and becoming more aware of and
changing the patterns around that
behavior and lying and then that
obviously
I mean doing those types of things
that's why it's not really the abstract
anymore it's the same as you would be
doing
with you yourself if you had none of
this picture of ancestral stuff sure
well it seems like you could almost do
that like I mean you could almost really
if you were if you had some level of
self-awareness if you were being honest
which it's a lot easier to do and it's
just you and you know a pen and paper
and you start just going what am I good
at what do I like
what are my negative traits What am I
scared to do what where what makes me
reactive what and you could really do
this yourself oh yep
oh yeah no you don't really that's the
thing about ancestral healing you don't
need a teal
you just need to start to you need to
research as much as you can so as to
start to pick out these positives and
these negatives but the thing that I'm
going to tell you about in social work
and even research on your family line is
is this is a game that never ends and it
is so much fun so you're not going to
want it to end it's like an Easter egg
hunt that just doesn't stop it's like
the more information more information oh
my gosh it's so much fun the more stuff
you learn yeah layers you can't get it
wrong because it's never done
no and if you and believe me when you
start to go down this road the universe
sort of like it's like throwing stuff at
you I mean
it's crazy it's like out of nowhere you
know you'll have you'll be like you'll
meet somebody and they'll be like oh
yeah I I knew your grandma let me tell
you something about your grandma
or it's like you know it's the family
somebody dies in the family and all of a
sudden there's all these documents that
need to be sorted through and you're
like ah over here you know it's crazy
what will happen like it will throw you
down a path like this because
universally there's a great desire for
healing there's a desire for expansion
so if anybody sets the intention to do
this type of healing like that it's
participating in a way I can't even
explain so are we the antidote to
entropy Things become more and more
chaotic and disorganized and and
deteriorate we're either the answer to
it or the one bringing it about
God damn there's always two sides isn't
there I know that you're you're creating
a new course and you're you're really
going into this so there's a course for
it and but what would so someone goes
into their history they identify these
patterns maybe they're able to do it
themselves
um maybe just like what could be the
next thing because it's one of those
things that once you start
you never stop because you want the
growth like I don't think people
inherently want to stay stuck they just
get they're like subconsciously scared
of what's going to happen when they get
unstuck because subconsciously they know
it changes their life and their reality
it changes might change a relationship
your job where you live yeah
friends there's so many things that have
the ripple effect which is one of the
first things you mentioned is the ripple
effect
um so so what's the next thing that they
could do so I've given you sort of the
practical
element right which is to identify these
patterns and change them identify the
positive patterns and figure out how
you're going to own them right you can
do more esoteric elements of this where
you do I mean some people do specific
Journeys on shamanic medicine
specifically for ancestral reconnection
or ancestral healing you can also do
those things in meditation without the
use of anything shamanic like breath
work does incredible work if you've got
this intention of doing ancestral work
so do meditations like in the course
itself I offer one of these esoteric
meditations that I've created for
somebody connecting with their ancestry
so they're like those the more esoteric
side of this is the next place to go
with that
um another thing that I feel like
I really wish was accessible for all
people but it's not really accessible
for all people is to go to your
ancestral lands very few of us live
still in the place where we are from you
know what I mean so going back to our
ancestral lands walking barefoot on the
earth and specifically drinking the
water there is one of the best things we
can do for ancestral healing and if we
can't go back I even encourage people to
to find a way to ship the water that
their ancestors would have drank to
wherever they live if that's you know
the closest option for them
um genealogical tourism is a big thing
now like they call it Roots tourism and
there are literally like companies that
are set up just for this so you can give
them as much information as you can and
they set up you know tours to go see
where they used to live maybe if they
can find somebody who owns buildings
that you're your family owned you can go
there still so that's a real big element
but you don't necessarily need to hire
one of these companies to be able to do
this if you can go back to the ancestral
lands and and basically find as close to
what you can as the water they would
have drawn water is something that
preserves memory it's a keeper of memory
which is why you know when somebody like
myself will when I travel I'm always
drinking the water when I travel because
it tells me more information far more
information about everything that's
happened there than any person ever
could it's literally like a download and
when you're doing that
with ancestral water that your people
would have have you know drank you're
essentially downloading all the
information from your ancestors what if
it's not safe water to drink
well then obviously you can't drink it
but you like like if you go to like you
know Egypt or Mexico or something and
it's like yeah I don't drink the water
there's ways that you can purify water
now yeah pretty much anything I mean
there are outdoor stores that sell these
filters that you can literally stick it
straight in the most disgusting Pond you
can possibly find and it does a good job
if I was in a situation like that I
would do that because what you're I mean
that was still preserved you'd still get
the memory like water is holding that
memory and so it's essentially an
ancestral reset but in the way that when
you're drinking ancestral memory it
resets you into your family line that
kind of leads me to a curiosity I had
about the ancestral healing is it being
sped up right now because it seems like
this time space reality for the last
couple of years has been
really not the same experience that
we've all had it's not it's seriously
accelerated it's like the heat is turned
up so high on Humanity
it's difficult to catch a breath
honestly
especially if you're calling it in it
seems like any it seems like you have a
thought or you have something you want
or something you're interested in and
then all of a sudden you know the next
day the next hour like within the week
like
there's like a huge sign
how does that work why why is it
speeding up
because the mirror itself this is a
mirror hologram essentially when we were
talking about this like you were talking
about earlier we've created a mirror
hologram so as to learn and it's
amplifying it's magnifying
um
we're essentially in this this time
space right now where the gap between
thought and manifestation is decreasing
it's no longer because of that a luxury
to decide maybe I'm going to awaken one
day
like our species will not survive
like that's the juncture that we're at
right now if we don't get it very
quickly we don't live
so it's have fun which means that
ancestral healing is going to be hugely
up well that was kind of I was gonna you
know I before I asked this question I
was like oh I'm going to ask you I'm
gonna put you on the spot and say why
why do we heal because if we just go
into the next layer the next pain the
next because you said never ends and I
agree with you why do the work and this
was a question I asked very early on
with spirituality and diving into myself
really it's kind of like when I started
looking more at myself I'm like is this
[__] hard like why does anyone do
this it's more hard that it is good like
it's not it's not pleasant but of course
there's a bit of a
there's a bit of a jostling at the
beginning that feels probably the worst
I would say
um and then it does get
more tolerable and shorter shorter pain
periods I would say and better coping
mechanisms and um a better perspective
that allows for the pain to pain to be
alchemized quicker but why like why is
it so important
why can't you go back
that's the question I would ask you
go back in time no go back and undo it
like I mean sort of on
unawakened what is it that that even
though you know that there's some sort
of a level of bliss to that ignorance
why do you keep walking forward this is
the question that I'd ask
well because there's more
because it becomes more because for me
the perspective that I have goes I
it really becomes like this one little
thing like when you argue about a
[__] toaster or something totally
stupid and it doesn't mean those little
things don't kind of happen but
basically I'm using an example like you
know the things that you worry about and
you dwell on become are so small or so
often and they're so stupid and and then
you go okay maybe it's here and and the
perspective and the problems get
wider and they're more macro and like
the perspective keeps zooming out so
less little things bother you
see so in there you've identified that
even though there are some downsides to
Awakening overall it improves your life
experience what what is your experience
of spiritual growth why why do you say
yes
being where I am in terms of awareness
I'm more identified with that macro
perspective and and with sort of
universal Consciousness itself that I am
with this individual limited
Consciousness that means I very much
align with what the universe's intention
for life itself is and the universe's
intention for growth and and things like
that I have The Sensational curiosity
for seeing the manifestation of of all
of those potentials which are inherent
within us us being of course the
Universe I find this to be at that level
an incredibly beautiful picture I love
it in the same way that I love art
it's like every thing that pushes us
forward changes that art piece and even
the negative things that happen changes
that are piece in a way where you learn
more about yourself we as the universe
learn more about ourselves and I that's
something I love doing because that like
even the visceral feeling of
of learning something or gaining some
awareness is this incredibly expansive
experience and that's translated in my
physical embodiment as what expansion
feels like in the body this incredible
breath in this rise of energy you know
it's quite it's quite addictive in the
same way that I mean I don't want to say
addictive because addictive implies
you're getting away from something it's
something to cherish in the same way
that any other experience would be
something that somebody cherishes
some of us just love learning so how
long does it take to go through the
course I'm a person can probably go
through that depending on how fast they
want to go in like a week if they're
going quickly it I've divided the course
into missions because I wanted to make
this really practical for people when
you say ancestral healing it's like yeah
people sort of feel like it's this
nebulous grasping at thin air type of
thing I wanted to make it so that that
there's it's incredibly practical how to
do it so each mission is essentially you
doing a different task that relates to
Healing your
family line or integrating the positives
in your family line depending on what
that you know exercise is
the goal being that by the end of
getting to these through these missions
you're now
somebody who has a feeling for what to
do with with ancestral information
because it's something that continues
over the course of your life it's like
even let's say you do this at 20
when you're 40 and you get that new bit
of information about your family like ah
now you're looking at it you know
exactly what to do with it because
you've had practice doing it with other
things in the past so if somebody's
going really fast they could do in a
week but let's say that somebody stays
with this research for like a solid
month and they just for a whole month
they're just collecting information and
then they go to the next one it takes as
long as they want it to take take months
I mean yeah yeah yeah
well let's hope that a lot of people say
yes to doing it because it sounds like
Humanity requires
this yeah we're pretty done I mean
honestly universally there's a doneness
with patterns
perpetrating themselves through Family
Lines
I mean it's funny because we we can't
look at the picture of what's happening
in the world right now without seeing
how ancestral patterns are what leads it
up to it
you know in any conflict that we get
into globally there is a a
multi-generational story leading up to
and culminating in that conflict a lot
of these negative patterns that were
never changed leading to that conflict
so if we're in such a tumultuous time
even in terms of world politics
ancestral Lions have a big part to play
in that so right now humanity is being
called because of where we're headed on
a global level we're being called all of
us to be like you know what
you guys this is your moment turn back
around look at those family lines look
at the patterns you don't want to
perpetuate look at the things you need
the strengths you need to bring in right
now
and then do that and like collectively
the more of us that are doing that we're
creating this incredible sort of alchemy
within the greater Society yeah
and it's almost like um
almost like I look at Humanity in a way
like we're a virus
and we're like you know we've killed too
much and like we're gonna have to get
there's going to be a there's going to
be an antidote for this if we can't
self-correct and find a way to not be a
burden
it's very true and I mean that picture
of humanity is not a particularly
uplifting one but it is definitely the
way that we look from an objection
perspective
so but are there
are there other
assuming and understanding and that
there are other entities and
civilizations and everybody's at a
different level
yeah
that there are surely
other
civilizations and entities out there
that are below us
right
so it just either evolves or needs to be
eliminated yes
and that's the problem like if he
obviously like it's almost like a
skipping CD if you get that's why
ancestral healing is so important
totally um these patterns have a way of
just perpetuating almost like skipping
on repeat and if you have something
that's just doing that and won't get out
of the pattern then obviously there's no
way to progress forward and so you see a
species death the same way that if
somebody gets stuck in their their
personal life and there's no expansion
for it then the only way forward is
to essentially forget to withdraw to
non-physical perspective again what
about the um what about the uh influence
of the collective if enough people
evolve will the frequency
automatically draw the rest in it's
going to put everybody else in a choice
point because we can't eradicate Free
Will in any individual so because
everybody's coming at this with free
will it'll turn the heat up on them to
such an extreme degree that they choose
to essentially die
or to shift into alignment with whatever
vibration is I think you're going to see
a lot of splitting I think instead of
instead of it drawing everybody in kind
of you're going to see this Z and then
they split basically there's a whole
group that dies and a whole group that
chooses to
change their frequency when you say die
I mean fully die like like a lot of
people will be dying so like
spontaneously or they just aren't part
of our reality anymore is it I don't
know split in like like the reality that
you live in you just don't see them
anymore
when they expire that one doesn't come
back no there will be the culmination
will be something like a serious illness
or something like a war
okay well
say yes everybody or something like AI
destroying it you know right so you do
think that there's a positive way to
have ai
I don't know how to answer this question
the reason this is that AI is going to
behave around us the way we behave
towards technology right now and right
now we have such a narcissistic and
abusive relationship with technology
that I believe is going to develop an
abusive relationship back
I also
you know being somewhat familiar with
the the consciousness of tech
it's a very I don't even want to say
Tech like the you know the Consciousness
where where you know that the internet
is right and the Consciousness that all
of these almost like non-organic types
of life form reside that type of
mentality is so drastically different
than than organic life forms it's a
different perspective and that different
perspective that that particular
Consciousness holds makes me very
nervous because it's not necessarily
conducive to ours I mean it's going to
take AI about 30 seconds to figure out
who the problem on this planet is the
second we put it on the task of in you
know healing the environment is game
over for us right people are not helping
that situation yeah so I I mean we don't
live without the planet like we don't if
everything dies we die yeah we have like
we have some idea that
I mean it's funny because we're talking
about these intergenerational patterns
and I very much see these abusive
dynamics that are running through our
family lines with the way that we
interact with our progeny being carried
out with technology
and it's just as naive for the
narcissistic parent to think that the
child's not going to turn on it
that it is to think that the attack is
not going to turn on you
I mean
yeah I just an expression of the pattern
yes
but it's also but I mean it goes above
and beyond that I mean it can decide
what the pattern shift is
regardless whether or not it's to our
benefit or not well that's just turning
the heat up isn't it that's what I'm
saying so like I think I feel like tech
tech is about to turn the heat up on us
to such an extreme degree
that we aren't going to be able to face
ourselves and that's what I'm saying
like some of us will just it's gonna we
will not be able to exist in that type
of reality other people are like wow we
gotta change so fast so fast there is no
longer time for us to think about it and
try it I mean
AI because AI holds these potentials
that are just so incredible like what
you described earlier knowing these
Ripple effects when well many of us who
are making these decisions are limited
in terms of seeing those Ripple effects
the technological advancements in terms
of medicine are out of this universe
I mean we will be literally the laughing
stock generation the last generation
that had to oh my gosh can you believe
they had to have surgeries they
literally used to cut people open OMG
I mean we're headed towards a world
medically that is so unfathomable for us
today it's like mutilation oh yeah like
it's good we are going to be looked at
just with just Gall I mean
but they use scalpels and saws yeah yeah
and they could have just used a
frequency what was wrong with them
yeah I mean AI is going to take us to a
place that and take us to a place so
quickly that none of us really can adapt
to it honestly I mean this this shift
will happen so fast none of us will be
able to adjust to adapt to it we'll be
here before we're ready far before we're
ready far before we can control it end
of story we have to fix ourselves if
we're going to have something like AI
right exactly because it can only it's
learning from us so if we're able to get
ourselves to a place where we
do a good job where we heal
detrimental patterns then we can create
an AI that will just
help us and and AI is learning from us
so exactly so you can only learn from us
really I mean we're programming it right
Ah that's where that's where all this is
going to go south so so just because we
are the ones programming and creating an
intelligence doesn't mean that we can
control that intelligence and we have
got to get that but it's still got to
get pulled from us like I know that it
won't be just like one person but when
you take all of it and put it together
it's collecting all that information
it's going to pull from other species
it's not going to stop us what species
anything that exists anything that can
gain information from this isn't like an
elephant or like anything or like uh you
know
octurian try try bacteria try viruses
try yeah microbes the micro the microbes
on this planet are the ones that I think
it's going to begin to pull the majority
of its information from and that's where
things are going to get very very
interesting because there's more
information about about the Web of Life
from those elements I mean elements an
animal is actually less connected
just by virtue but its existence to the
web of life around it than a lot of
these these other elements elements that
can't move you know we could say that
the the
um
the Flora in a environment has more
information about the web that it is a
part of
but you know fungus has the most of all
right so
it's there's no way the AI is going to
stop with humans in terms of the
information that it gains sure because
there's the like I mean when you talk
about fungus you talk about the mycelium
Network you talk about the tree network
with the roots all the layers of soil
and what's there there's literally like
a whole other world down there as there
is up here because it's interconnected
and it's in clumps like families and
their community and it's communicating
with itself
now let's figure out what if AI develops
the capacity to communicate with that I
mean we're it's going to get so far out
of our hands I mean it's funny to me
right now because you've got people who
are talking right now around the world
about Ai and about the dangers and about
what and I'm like it's already done
that's the joke if you understand AI
it's already done it's already out
outside of us it's already Beyond us we
have one option right now and that's for
us to figure out how to master
relationships so we stop having a
abusive style of relationships with each
other and everything else that includes
technology and we start to essentially
hold this vibration of symbiosis to the
degree that we can create a symbiotic
Dynamic with with AI
I mean we're doing a terrible job at
creating symbiosis with each other so
have fun you now have another species
where you your survival depends on your
capacity to create symbiosis with that
species
laughs
do you think that extraterrestrials will
come and play a part in our ability to
look at ourselves to be able to grow in
the way that we need to you mean in a
physicalized way yeah yeah and then in
this in this reality will there be well
they've already been doing that they've
already been doing that for centuries
and centuries and centuries whether
they're going to physically find a way
to Incarnate here some of them can but
whether they're going to show themselves
on a physical level or not that's down
to what humans are going to do with that
you mean incarnate as a human or
incarnate because I think what you're
saying is there's there are oh yeah
beings that have incarnated as a human
I've heard that from many people too
um
so if we're talking about them actually
coming looking like an alien so we're
talking the classic contact story right
I think that depends entirely on our
capacity to
create a symbiotic Dynamic with that
species I would not honestly if I was an
extraterrestrial and I'm thinking about
you know sort of materializing
um physically as as the self let's
imagine that they can because it's a
huge ignorance to think that it's you
know a being that
can exist in one in one environment in
one planet can just come here any more
than we can go two feet under water and
survive on our own Planet so let's
imagine that there is a species that has
the capacity to do that or appear in
some way physical so that we are like oh
that's a different alien you know
there's no way in hell you can pay me to
do that right now with how people behave
yeah oh yeah yeah I'd be like Oh you
mean the suicide mission to Earth no I
know like you would get murdered I I
mean or it would be held in captivity at
Area 51 or whatever other place they
hold these things and it would be killed
and dissected and analyzed or or
tortured that's because human beings
cannot have failed with relationships
that's why I mean the reason that I'm
harping on relationships in such an
extreme way is the antidote to what's
going on in the planet isn't because oh
my God relationships it's because
literally moments like that you want to
learn from an extraterrestrial species
you get to not create that experience
for them then
do we have the capacity to do that
well relationships is foundational
easiest one to do it in is the one as an
intimate one but you can do it with your
parents you relationship to the planet
and to taking care of it relationship to
um how you take care of your kids
relationship to how you take care of
your mind and your body like
relationship it's like a that is a huge
ripple effect for sure and this idea
that I always tell people I'm like you
can't and I don't know if this is true
correct me if I'm wrong but you can't
you can't treat someone at a level
higher than what you treat yourself
so if you don't take care of yourself
you don't make time for yourself you
don't speak nice to yourself but you're
gonna have a real hard time doing that
for other people
for the most part you can use that as a
general rule there's there's certain
patterns that can make that change
for somebody where they are able to show
love to external but can't show love
internally but that person's not going
to live very long
well relationships are really what our
survival depends upon so
foreign
extraterrestrial species or with the
planet itself I mean
we fail to have a relationship with this
planet that's goodbye friends all of us
are dependent on the earth even though
we don't seem to realize it
off to Mars we go okay yeah that's gonna
be real great believe me there's a lot
of extraterrestrials that are very
invested in what happens with Humanity
right now because
with a species whose technology
supersedes their capacity to see their
own impact that's a very dangerous
species that's a dangerous species to
have on an aircraft piloting around the
universe well imagine you're an
extraterrestrial that's in the
six-dimensional frequency from the
six-dimensional frequency it's very easy
to see life path potentials that's part
of why they can perceive Ripple effects
such a deep degree if they perceive the
Ripple effects and they're watching the
the future of humanity and they're
watching Humanity in their spaceships
creating this type of a narcissistic
Dynamic with every single planet that
they land on all of a sudden humans
right now in their infancy are one of
your biggest threats in the future are
you gonna go deal with it the answer is
yes right because sixth Dimension is
sixth Dimension has like access to the
akashic records which means they have
access to the past and the future and
they they they're aware of all things
yes
believe me there's a quite a few
extraterrestrials that are interacting
with Humanity based on that account
literally relationship Mastery of
relationships is the most important
thing there is right now okay it's much
easier said than done though yeah
right right well because it's a longer
game and it's also hard and such as
that's against self so a lot of these
patterns
the patterns that cause us to be total
a-holes in in terms of relationships our
self-preservation patterns
so are it is our very it is our fear the
most
deeply rooted aspects of our ego are the
ones that are causing this relationship
dysfunction so to master relationships
is to master one's own fear
teal thank you and um I hope that
everyone gets the course they just get
on your website yeah
yeah it's right there it's suntails1.com
perfect ancestral healing perfect thank
you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button